our next speaker is Timothy a little
crap Timothy the lookout from deep-brain
in London yeah okay so I'm gonna talk
today a bit about something I've been
interested in for for a long time which
is back prop and the brain and whether
back prop has anything to tell us about
it and how I've been kind of thinking
about that for a while there's lots of
people that have been involved in some
of the work I'm gonna talk about but I'm
gonna be kind of just going through
various pieces I'd particularly like to
just note um Sergey Barton of and Jordan
who have done especially some of the
experiments that show up in this but
yeah there's lots of people involved in
all of these things so I've kind of I
guess there's this this side it's about
the credit assignment problem which I
think comes up in cortex all over the
place which is basically this right that
if if something some information comes
into a primary sensory area and then
eventually that leaves two leads to a
motor a motor output or some sort of
associative concept area where you're
forming some decision about something
then there's you know there's some sort
of series of processing along the way
and really the behavioral effects those
downstream behavioral effects depend on
those earlier activity and and on the
whole chain along the way and in some
sense the the problem for the brain is
is how to say how to adjust those those
say those blue synapses in abstract
based on what happens in the downstream
behaviors that take place and I think
it's fair to say now that effectively
this is this this problem is is in
artificial networks essentially it's
solved one way and that is with back
prop so we you know we compute the
derivative of some error with respect to
the weights on our network and we update
parameters and there's lots of things
like a demand rmsprop that are sort of
better than just standard SGD like this
but they all basically just make use
backprop to compute to compute the
gradients and make updates and I want to
make a point here that this is this is
also true and I'm actually going to hit
this point a little harder later too
this is also really true not only in
supervised cases where we're doing
something like image net but also in the
reinforcement learning algorithms that
have been successful recently on hard
problems and in unsupervised cases right
so all the best unsupervised algorithms
are running as well are all under the
hood so two people are training the
backdrop and so I think it's sort of
worth worth inquiring you know does back
prop have anything to tell us about how
the brain is doing hard problems and
it's a it's probably even now a bit of a
contentious problem contentious proposal
it certainly has been
but maybe it's becoming less of a
contentious proposal okay so right so so
I think neuroscientists have been happy
with the idea I mean just just to flesh
this out a bit more happy with the idea
for a long time that we have we have
learning rules that operate on sort of
sort of two layers or relatively shallow
in some sense but you know in a network
that's got a network that's deep in some
sense then in order to credit you know
this synapse down here between a and B I
really need to know something about the
downstream structure of my own brain
right and that's what backprop says and
that's indeed what I think to do
learning effectively you should do and
so there's a real question about how to
do that you should know something how to
know something about the structure of
your own downstream brain and how to use
that to make updates and earlier layers
so just to recap I'll spend a bit of
time here why why isn't back prop
biologically plausible because I think
it should be said even though I think
back prop in some sense has something to
tell us about the brain obviously and
it's in just like the purest form I
think it's not running in the brain I
mean that's kind of clear and there's a
bunch of reasons so here's a just a two
layer network and you know we we take
the derivatives of some error with in
this case we end up you know we just
take and use the chain rule and get this
expression at the end and this kind of
summarizes I think why people have
complained about back prop and
rightly so so there's various things
here so it says um the weights in the
lower layer ought to be changed
according to this expression that
expression involves an error term it
involves using the downstream weight
matrices it involves using the
derivative of the local activation
function the last one is pretty easy
that's just the the presynaptic input to
that hidden layer and as well it also
back prop really involves a separate
forward and backward passes which isn't
really in that equation but you know you
need to do these two things you need to
do a forward pass and then you need to
do a backward pass and there's lots of
things okay so there's lots of things to
say about these pieces and I'm just
gonna say a few of them and then hit
more of them as I as I go along the
error term was really a huge worry for
people for ages I I guess I kind of want
to say here when backprop kind of
arrived on the scene people were using
it in a supervised setting but I think
now it's kind of clear that you can have
an error term arriving from
reconstruction losses there are from
your unsupervised your unsupervised
algorithm you can have instead of just a
normal error term in a supervised
setting you can have a policy gradient
that shows up in a similar in a similar
sense so when you're doing reinforcement
learning so I think that that that sense
that the error term is like a big
boogeyman is I think it's sort of dying
the second one the transpose of the the
downstream weight matrices I mean I
think that's still very real I mean it's
not like I think no one thinks that the
this that this is a reasonable thing for
the brain to have hold of and to use in
earlier layers that is like real perfect
transposes of downstream weights the
derivative of the activation function I
don't think is that big a deal I mean
this thing is sort of basically a simple
function of the input to those neurons I
don't think it's that hard to imagine
computing something like this if you
wanted to but then the other one this
separate forward and backward passes is
also probably pretty pretty out there in
some sense so that is that you would
actually do sort of a forward prop
through your network and then compute a
back prop quite separately and then use
that to do updates right so that's
that's usually the kind of set
at least some set of the things that
people worry about when they worry about
his back prop or something like it
operating the brain but I want yeah I do
want to dig into these a little bit more
but I'm gonna start by sort of
mentioning you know there's been some
recent indirect evidence and this has
been noted I think by a couple people
here coming from the DeCarlo lab and
from kreega's quartz lab sorry if I'm
butchering those names that are showing
that look if we take big networks and we
train them with backdrop and we pose
talk look into the representations and
we post talk look into the
representations these things that this
thing doesn't work that's okay these
these these things that are trained and
do better in terms of say classifying
images do better at do better at letting
you sort of predict the variants in v4
and i.t neurons and you see that that's
even better
in the case of higher higher level
neurons and these in these kind of
convolutional networks but that's pretty
indirect right I mean it doesn't say
that says that though some of the
representations formed look a bit like
what you get in a backrub Network but it
doesn't tell you how you got there and
that's kind of what I'm I'm a bit
obsessed about is how how do you get a
big deep network that does powerful
things like be able to operate on
imagenet how did it get to that state
okay so I think it's it's it's pretty
it's pretty important in some sense to
have this kind of a picture in mind
which is that there's a there is really
a huge spectrum I think of credit
assignment credit assignment algorithms
that might be working in a deep network
that has a bunch of connections through
and on one side in some sense I would
say okay you have something like
backprop where you compute exactly the
gradients and you make exactly these
kinds of weight updates - although - all
the weights in your network and you do
that well and and you know that you sort
of do it precisely you give yourself
precise knowledge of all the downstream
connections on the other far end you
have something along the lines of weight
perturbation or activity perturbation
which are simple reinforced style
learning algorithms which basically say
I'm going to take so the e here are the
sort of
something about a performance metrics an
error or a performance metric I'm gonna
look at how my performance metric
changes as a function of say noise that
I inject into my weights or into my
activities and I'm gonna look at
correlations between those things and
then I'm gonna make weight updates based
on those correlations so it's kind of
the simplest thing you could do and it's
a great it's a great idea in many ways
and in certain settings it works okay it
should be said that I think there's been
a sense at least historically in
neuroscience that this kind of learning
this code of correlation with a global
global signal of change in performance
has in it is what drives a lot of
learning in the brain and I think
there's good reasons for that the good
reasons to have thought that for example
you do see things like dopamine
delivered globally in the brain or
fairly globally in the brain and that
looks a bit like you transmitted
something like a performance a global
performance indicator right but what's
what's troubling what's what's trouble
with the this sort of left side of the
spectrum is that it doesn't actually
work very well in practice when you
train on large networks with hard tasks
and notably I think as far as I'm aware
no one has used these kinds of
techniques ever to be able to sort of
successfully train a large network on
something like image net it's it's just
really I think probably does not work in
my hands anyway even smaller scale
things than that really don't work and
and the reason it's very simple the
reason is very simple as you increase
the number of neurons and then in the
network as you increase the number of
weights those correlations mean that
those those the fact that you're sort of
just doing this via correlations know
those weight updates means that the
variants on your gradient estimator gets
worse and worse and worse as the number
of neurons blows up so there are things
in between and that's what I'm going to
talk a bit about today is you know what
what what lies in between the space and
I think what lies in between the space
is tons and tons of algorithms that we
haven't really explored all that well
that know something about the downstream
structure that approximate
something about the downstream structure
and use that to make weight updates that
are much better than at that end but
maybe not quite backdrop yeah already
real the real brain we understand that
we know that the document is not
secreted everywhere I mean there are
projections of certain areas that as
well I just wonder has there been
attempts of trying to solve which
something like this on the left side is
maybe being somewhat more realistic in
terms of spatial temporal dynamics sure
sure so that's a good question and I
think the short answer is not nearly
enough and I wish people more people
would because I think we need to we need
to understand this whole spectrum better
as I said in my hands even on something
like medium sized datasets the left-hand
side things like this trying to salvage
something like the left-hand side has
been really hard like even after two or
three layers of neurons and things like
this I can't even get things to take off
reasonably using that sort of those sort
of approaches it doesn't mean it can't
be done
I mean if we've learned anything
recently it's that negatives you know
don't mean a whole lot so please I mean
my failure on that case you know I would
it would be great to see more people try
and see if they could in fact so I'll
say a little bit very very briefly about
this more which is so here's here's sort
of learning on em missed these are this
is this is just this is just em inist
here's back prop in the blues with
varying numbers of neurons in it with a
couple layers in hidden layers
the others are node perturbation and
weight perturbation where you're yeah
use same structure network and you're
sort of seeing you're doing all the
weight updates using weight perturbation
node perturbation and even on em NIST
these are reasonably well tuned as week
as far as we can tell and even on m-miss
this is insanely slow to sort of to
learn these things and in harder and
harder datasets we feel like I haven't
even be able to get these things to take
off reasonably at all we don't
understand this only why that is but
it's theoretically in some limit these
things should work but but it's sort of
what is that limit in terms of number of
samples and number of data trials on the
other hand we have things like
argue prop variance which I'll talk a
bit about more which which can do a
pretty good job so these are M nest and
one of the medium-sized data sets I
talked about Street View house numbers
where they do about as well as back prop
and on these data sets anyway abound as
well as backdrop and abound as quickly
so there are other algorithms out there
which don't make some of the assumptions
that back prop does that do decently and
I'll kind of dig into that a bit more as
I go okay so I want to I want to say
that this is also sort of maybe back to
this point I mean I think that there was
a good reason for a neuroscientists all
long to believe that something like back
prop is going on and and like I said too
for a machine learner an appeal to the
variance in grading estimators is often
enough you can kind of just sort of
spell that out to them and they're
pretty happy but it's really enough to
convince neuroscientists and and so I
kind of I think that first of all I want
to say what do I mean by something like
back prop and this is what I mean and
it's that learning is achieved across
multiple layers by sending information
from neurons so detailed information
from neurons closer to the output per
output back to earlier layers to help
compute their synaptic updates now
that's kind of what I mean by something
like back prop and I think you know if
we think about that if you kind of
believe in some very basic things that
we I think we just know about cortex
then you you should be almost on the
same page already that that's going on
in the brain and the specific form of it
we have very little idea but the
generalities we know and that is because
feedback connection come in cortex are
ubiquitous they're really all over the
place that is from area back to earlier
err areas and they those connections
people have shown modify the activity in
spiking in neurons and earlier layers
and the second thing is that plasticity
and the forward connections can be
driven by pre and postsynaptic spiking
eg it's sort of like stdp protocols and
so if you just put those together the
feedback connections are going to modify
the spike times of these guys which
means that you're going to change how
the the forward connections are being
learned so
almost almost almost sort of just by by
simple derivation the the something like
back prop is going on now the specific
size I said have all to be sort of
worked out and you could still claim
that those modifications are kind of
epic phenomenal and don't aren't doing
anything interesting but it seems it
would seem like a little crazy to me you
know why have all those feedback
connections why I have them do things
like modify learning in earlier layers
okay I also want to kind of hit as I
said again this point about
reinforcement learning I mean it's clear
that the brain is making massive use of
reinforcement learning and I think it's
good to have a clear view of how how
sort of back prop like things and
reinforcement learning might be fitting
together and and what that means and to
sort of make sure we're teasing those
apart nicely and have it clear in our
heads so here's the sort of standard
reinforcement learning block diagram
where you've got an agent say composed
of a bunch of networks that's getting
observations and wards and sending
actions to an environment and and what
we've what we have what what people have
been doing a lot recently what I've been
spending a lot of my time doing is sort
of doing RL with big big networks and I
think it's worth just sort of looking
walking through that a tiny bit to see
how we think about now that hooks up
with something like backdrop and so here
is a single trial trial of reinforcement
learning right you know you start in
some state you run through some policy
network you produce an action you sample
from that policy network you produce an
action get a reward transition to a new
state and so on through time you know
you've got a trajectory here and you can
if you wanted to compute the probability
of a trajectory in this in this way and
if you do a bit of if you do a bit of
math well so so actually before I get
there so you know what do we do as far
as outcomes you know we would do
something like compute the return for a
single trial which is some discounted
sum of rewards and then our objective
function is like you know what you
really care about is integrating over
all the possible trajectories you you
need or your policy would take you to
what are the returns associated with
those trajectories and integrating that
over all the trajectories you might
reach you know okay so then
what we what people are doing a lot now
in RL and with with deep networks is
something like this it should use a
model free policy gradient setup which
in some sense bears a lot of resemblance
to what I talked about earlier this sort
of simple way of updating weights and
you would roll out a trajectory see what
happens
compute you know compute performance
metrics and all this but then basically
just take take the derivative in some
sense a sample derivative of your of
your objective function and this is I
suppose the really important part you
that kind of splits into two parts where
you kind of do the RL part in these
reduced actions action space action
spaces and then you still at the end of
the day take the derivatives back
through your big deep network and if you
weren't doing that you'd be in a lot of
trouble to learn the sorts of learning
the sorts of complicated behaviors we
can now learn so this is an agent that's
gotten raw pixels and rewards and and
learns to go around and collect objects
in an environment and learn to do it
relatively successfully so the basic
agent would just like run into the walls
and all these kinds of things and this
is kind of almost it is basically almost
becoming old hat but I think it's worth
dwelling here on on the you know what
what are the relationships between
reinforcement learning and and
algorithms like back prop and the
relationship is exactly is that we use a
bunch of RL but we are combining it with
back prop and and that's really crucial
so this still takes hundreds of millions
of steps even with back prop so if you
were instead sitting there and doing the
sort of updates to your weights you know
you got a policy gradient up at the top
and then from that point on you did
correlative based updates to the weights
in your network without taking into
account the structure of the network
this hundreds of millions would get
you're basically intractably worse right
intractably worse so we basically just I
think it just probably would not work
I'm happy to have people prove me wrong
but that's that's my my my sense of
things at the moment okay so now having
having I think that there's a similar
story to tell for unsupervised learning
again that like all the all the sort of
stuff that we're doing recently there's
some cool stuff talked about with
pregnant and so on that we was discussed
yesterday all these things I think
basically used back prop and and so some
sort of replacement for it is worth
worth looking for that's pretty loud
okay so I'm gonna go back a bit to this
question and and talk a bit about some
actual attempted replacements and some
some ideas from the recent neuroscience
literature so yeah again why isn't back
prop biologically plausible these are
some of the reasons one of the things
that I got interested in particularly in
part because it was one of the big
things that people sort of were worried
about is this transpose of downstream
weights so knowing about your own
internal structure so right and and this
is this was actually coined historically
this has coined the weight transport
problem I think in 87 in a paper by
Grossberg
so the aid in 1986 back prop was
published 1987 Grossberg published a
paper and talked about some of the
issues with thinking about back prop as
saying anything about the brain and one
of the issues he pointed out was this
issue of needing to know about w1 in
order to update w0
and Aquinas the weight transport problem
and if in the literature through the 80s
and 90s it was probably one of the
biggest cited issues with back problem
so you know why do you need to do this
why did why do you need to do this this
is the sort of basic figure I mean back
prop sends sends error back precisely
through symmetric sets of synapses and
this I think everyone would generally
agree neuroscience looks crazy having
sort of these precise set of synapses in
that backward error path as in your
forward path forward now I think
surprisingly so I did some work playing
around with thinking about whether you
could learn backward weights so you say
forget about trying to forget about
trying to sort of like use that
transpose could you actually learn these
backward weights and in the process
during control experiments actually
stumbled on something even weirder which
was that for a lot of problems even if
you just took a backward wait
be you just sampled it randomly and then
froze it actually things work remarkably
well so this this figure is basically
showing a very very simple problem but
the the upper lines are sort of some
shallow learning reinforcement learning
along the lines of node perturbation
that I talked about the black line is
back prop and this green line is what
I'd called feedback alignment where you
just fix those backward weights toward
some random set and you just did
learning as usual otherwise and
essentially you see this thing tracks
back prop really pretty well on this
problem this is showing that actually
over time there's there the the sorts of
updates that feedback alignment was
making come too close more closely
resemble those of backdrop and you don't
have to have them come so zero would be
if they were exactly what backdrop was
doing and they don't have to be perfect
in order to get you can see you don't
have to be perfect in order to get
learning that looks very much like
backdrop so that's part of the I think
part of the idea here is that you don't
have to know perfectly about your doubt
the downstream structure of the network
that you're dealing with you should
maybe just have some idea about it and
that that might work now here it looks
like you have no idea about it because B
is just told yep that's a great question
and and and in fact empirically yes it
is
yeah and I'll show you that in a second
so just very quickly this also works for
things like Amnesty and some harder
datasets and I'll get I'll come to sort
of like you know where where we really
stand now but this is sort of M missed
and you can see the Green is performing
about as well as back prop and you see
sort of similar dynamics in this in
terms of this what do the weight updates
look like do they look like what back
prop is doing yep so for training
there's no feedback projections
so w so in both cases there's feedback
projections in the back prop case that's
the sort of normal back prop case you
use exactly the transpose of W which alt
which changes as W changes of course in
this case they're only used they're only
used during learning that's right in
this case they're only used for learning
as well
that's right and I and I think it should
be said that is one of the other things
that I think is I mean it wasn't listed
in my slide but it's one of the other
issues that is clearly objectionable
amount back problem we know that the
feedback connections in cortex are
actually alter activity in earlier
layers whereas the feedback connections
in back prop really you're only there
for learning
you can literally throw them away there
like you know but I think that these
things can live together and I'll talk a
bit a bit more about that so in any case
so yeah B is this unstructured thing
that just sampled the beginning of
learning and fixed yep sorry
yes that is true yes well then that's
right so I would say by going my I don't
think I don't think that they're just
for learning but I think I mean there's
been some like talk about this yesterday
my guess would be that they're mostly
for learning and that the the kind of
the just to wax a little bit that
they're probably sort of to do not you
in the right direction for for inference
so you sort of say okay you should move
in this direction and then having moved
in that direction a bit you look at
those Delta's and those Delta's
inference wise tell you oh you know you
should do that more more in future
instead of having to compute it via the
feedback you know the forward
connections you just do that in future
but yeah
the are the synaptic weights that you're
talking about if you ever look at a
synapse there are very low resolution
things they might have 10 or 15 ampere
channels in them so are we have you
quantified or will you comment later on
the ability for this entire scheme to
work when you have very low resolution
weights before learning including in
your scheme if you were going to assume
the back awkwardly directed weights they
would also be it's a great question I
think like loosely I think it doesn't
there's been a bunch of work in machine
learning recently specifically around so
first of all definitely around trying to
have fewer bits you know in your in your
representation of weights and in fact
there's a whole little sub community who
care not at all about neuroscience but
love the idea of getting rid of tons and
tons of bits both in the activations and
then the weights because they want to
run things on your cell phone so so
there is a community who is doing that
who's understanding you know who's
trying to understand when I want to
train those kinds of networks can I do
it with very few bits and the answer is
look I think the end the short answer is
yeah roughly and people are making
progress on it it's certainly not solved
in the sense that you can get exactly
the kinds of performance you can with
like 32 bit floating stuff everywhere
but people are making reasonably good
progress on it in that in that niche
yeah okay so so very quickly one of the
things that we actually see happening
someone asked this question was that
when you go and look at the the weights
W they actually do they actually do sort
of a line so if we look at all the
synapses blue this is sort of some we're
looking at some sort of alignment
between the backward weights and the
forward weights and they are the this
over the progress process of training is
is getting closer and B is fixed so this
must be happening in W and indeed this
is kind of what we believe is going on
in this in this kind of weird situation
which is that
there's there's first of all some
transfer of information about the
content a B into W not buy updates then
W not actually that that information
that information about B actually gets
transferred up into W once you've had
that happen there's this course of
Correspondence formed between W and B
and then in the third phase then
actually you can have reasonably decent
learning happen and you know deep
learning happen that is the error
transmitted via B is affected for W not
and I think I mean it's really we're
saying I think that the it's really
worth not overstating the importance of
this in the sort of trying to figure out
what's going on in cortex it's more that
I think this was an illustration that
there's gonna be a lot of learning
algorithms you ones that even surprised
us a lot where you can know very roughly
about your downstream weights and that's
good enough to do much much better
learning than simple RL reinforced style
things in this one feedback sending
signals say per neuron in the hidden
layer sorry and I think I mean probably
the biggest distinction right between
something like a standard reinforced
style algorithm and what you would do in
backdrop is you deliver in backdrop
vector based error to all of your
neurons which is really sort of computed
and individualized for those guys and
you use detailed feedback to do that and
that's those are the things that I think
are important rather than just a global
scalar delivery was there another
question
sure so there's lots of things again I
mean there's a whole bunch and actually
maybe I'll get on to some of these other
ones where you would maybe choose train
B and so on in a moment
other people have is the short answer
yeah okay so I also want to just comment
very briefly on some of the energy based
model stuff which was talked about
yesterday and I suspect that this stuff
has a lot in the end
tell us about things people I think have
liked in the literature around back prop
have liked energy based stuff because
you don't have this weird forward phase
and then backward phase that are
completely disjoint what you do is
something like this you have a network
which is full of recurrent units you run
a positive phase where you clamp you
clamp these that you clamp some say data
and target to the network you and you
you let this thing evolve till until
it's it's done in some sense you have
what's called a negative phase where
you'd say just clamp the data and let
the whole thing run and say output its
own it's our own target and importantly
when you do this the the way that you
update the hidden units is you integrate
stuff from the the forward connections
and things from the backward connections
and it's really the difference between
these phases that's used to drive
learning so that the weight updates are
a function of a function of looking
across these phases at the moment
empirically these are these these
algorithms are a bit problematic
basically because you need fairly long
settling phases that look a little bit
crazy but I think people are hopeful
that maybe some of that can be dealt
with so I actually think there's
probably insight to be had in the energy
based model direction empirically it's
sort of it's been hard to make them work
at scale in part because these long
settling times especially if you have
many layers of neurons but it's it's
worth putting them into this road map
one of the things that I've been more
interested in recently is just this
question and is that the that is that do
any of the existing biologically
motivated learning algorithms scale up
to solve really hard credit assignment
problems and and I think I'm going to
show you spoiler is like a bit of a
negative
we don't have much and I think that's
interesting in its own right then
there's a lot more work to do there so
I'm gonna talk about one specific bit of
work we did with an algorithm called
different target prop and variants of it
which we took as kind of I thought maybe
one of the nicest starting points to
investigate that question and basically
we took it because it did a satisfied a
couple things it said okay it does get
rid of whey transport almost and we have
a variant of it where we did get rid of
weight transport entirely and we also
tried it in the context where we didn't
do any weight tying as in for the
convolutions and we also wanted to try
and get rid of sind error signals which
i think is one of the issues in backdrop
or you can certainly point to and say
you know look it doesn't really look
like what we're transmitting back
through feedback connections they're
signed signed errors I should say that
when we did these experiments we still
have all of these issues we're still
using continuous rather than spiking
signals we're still violate dales law we
still do use separate and forward and
backward passes and local activity
derivatives and your personal complaint
here but in some ways I think the the
the the are part of our impetus recently
has been like look do we have any
algorithms on the table which for the
really well-known constraints can do
anything decent on big problems so okay
so here's the algorithm here's the sort
of starting point for these this class
of algorithms which is target
propagation and this goes back to an
algorithm that an idea a set of ideas
from yan in the the 80s and the idea is
very simple and kind of nice and I think
actually agrees with a lot of the ideas
that people have talked about here which
is which is this you do some forward
pass through some network and then to
begin with let's assume you have perfect
inverses for those layers so then you
can take a target up at the top and
basically project it through these
inverses and say well if I wanted to get
that target as an output what should
have my activity been here in these
layers in order to perfectly produce
that target at the output so these you
can think about is basically top-down
expectations so it's sort of I got this
inverse i compute down through it you
should
have been this and then just layer wise
I do a simple difference between between
these things and I update the weights so
that I would have landed closer to this
thing in future if I saw that pattern
right so in some sense it's like dead
simple and it's kind of lovely it's it's
it's using top down expectations it etc
it's transporting across layers not
errors but activities so that's what
it's sending across layers there's
expectations about what the lower layer
should have been in practice this
algorithm doesn't really work very well
unfortunately and so there was a fellow
in yoshua bengio slab called dong-hyun
who who worked on this idea called DIF
target prop and it's I think the details
are maybe the details are maybe not too
worth going on going into here but the
main notion was okay it's it's obviously
unrealistic to have these perfect
inverses so what what what he did was he
said I'm gonna learn imperfect inverses
going back through the layers just using
an autoencoder reconstruction loss so
I'm gonna try and reconstruct what was
sent up from here up and then down so
I'm gonna learn these imperfect inverses
and I'm gonna use those imperfect
inverses to send so first of all to send
targets just as I didn't last the last
slide but I can also use the
reconstruction here as a way to correct
those targets and make them better and
make them better and this algorithm does
nominally work reasonably well for at
least small and mid-sized problems and
also to the point maybe back there it
explicitly says yeah maybe we should
learn the backward weights and so they
you do updates on the backward weights V
here so you have basically layer wise
layer wise losses layer wise learning
rules that operate at every layer and
you have them both for the forward and
backward weights right now this in
practice the actual version that they
wrote about still used back prop at the
very top level we worked on a variant
where we sort of got rid of the
gradients completely at that top level I
don't think it's too germane here but
we looked at this a bit and then we
looked at a bunch of data sets running
from eminence all the way up to image
net and we looked at fully connected and
locally connected networks and by
locally connected I mean not commnets
but where you do weight sharing but you
actually get rid of that and kind of saw
and thought to see how well these things
would work in practice so here is the
rough story which is that on em nest you
can kind of do pretty well with this
this kind of thing and and and do get
replicate original results get good
accuracy great in Street View house
number and sort of going on down the
story is that the gap between different
stargate prop and our variants of it
widened a bit so that by the time you
get down to see far and you're working
with locally connected architectures in
c far they're actually ends up being
pretty large gaps pretty large gaps in
performance and basically this is
because different target prop is
producing approximations to those
gradients and there's some variance to
those estimators and probably even some
bias to those estimators which might be
even worse that produce these suboptimal
learning results you can kind of see
this very briefly here maybe it's just
best to look at the learning curves
where these guys are these guys here our
variance of our backdrop in these
architectures and the other ones up
there are the other guys up there in
these bands if you like our variance of
target prop okay so the real one for us
though was you know these things were
still kind of working reasonably well
the real thing we wanted to look at was
scaling this all the way up to imagenet
which is we which is something that we
know humans can do reasonably well and
so we're like you know this was I should
I should mention the the result here is
obviously pretty negative but I thought
this was the best one we had on the
table in some sense right so I think it
wasn't I actually think dong-ha
dong-hyun did some great work and this
was kind of like I was excited this was
like the best thing on the table that
didn't violate weight transport and so
on anyway this is the basic result back
prop
backprop in this kind of I should say
these results are not particularly good
for imagenet but this is a relatively
small network that we're training this
on for various reasons I can get into
but the the important thing is the
different target prop and all the
variants we explored are up there in
that little band so that you can barely
they basically can't even get get off
the ground in these relatively small
networks five to seven layers of locally
connected units and so on so there
they're really just not doing well on
this and the short story there is I
think we need to be looking for other
algorithms that sit somewhere in that
spectrum in the middle ground of that
spectrum spectrum okay so I think that
was a bit of a negative story I want to
tell a bit more of a positive story
coming from the the neuroscience front
which is you know we've learned a lot
more about neurons and people made
reference to the the point the point
neurons stuff and I completely agree I
think we've been trapped when we've been
trying to think about and dream about
imagine new algorithms that might be
operating in the brain we've really been
trapped by thinking about point neurons
and this is one of the big reasons I
think if you think that things are point
neurons in cortex then you think that
when feedback feed-forward activity and
feedback activity arrives into a neuron
basically those voltages just get
totally mixed together and the neuron
has no idea which is which right it's
like what is feedback and what is
feed-forward I mean there's no there's
no discriminating it's all just voltages
just get smushed into my you know into
my soma and that I that I think is a big
that has really held a step back
nowadays coming from you know coming
from the neuroscience side we have a
much much richer much more interesting
picture of what neurons in court
especially in cortex do and and I might
be doing and so we think for example
that there really is strong electrotonic
segregation in some of these neurons
where feed-forward activity is arriving
into a very different compartment say
from feedback activity from other areas
and cortex and that not only that not
only is there compartmentalization
but the communications between say the
basil and the apical the basal apical
depart compartments of these things
though
communications are are interesting and
rich and sparse and dictated by various
mechanisms so you have BAPS going back
up you have calcium spikes that come
down and there's lots of dynamics that
sort of surround that and you have
interneurons which synapse on to some of
these proximal things that can
additionally control the communication
between these compartments so not only
are they communicating but you actually
have control and I think the picture
that this is summoning for me is you can
start to dream up and think about
algorithms where the forward pass and
the backward pass really is semi
separable so you have some semi
separable 'ti between these things and
you even have possibly control over how
those forward and backward passes talk
to each other so there's some very cool
work by Urban's a concern who were
thinking about this not in a deep
learning scenario but we're thinking
about multi compartment neurons and
learning and one of the things that they
pointed out in this cool paper and
neuron was that they could actually take
this multi compartment neuron think
about doing the error computations
internal to a cell rather than trying to
think about having error shipped around
and that by doing that actually things
could be made much sort of nicer with
respect to how you think about the
biology and so here they're getting the
cell to sort of track some track some
signal over time but you could do it in
this multi compartment way in you know
where whereas if you tried to do this
with point neurons it would look
hopeless and it would look like terribly
biologically implausible so we spent a
bit of time with some collaborators with
Jordan and with Blake Richards thinking
about how you could integrate those
ideas into deep learning deep learning
style algorithms and the the sort of
short version is we're thinking about
how to sort of ship information back
from higher layers to then sort of the
apical dendrites in lower layers and in
we can get these things to kind of
nominally work in sort of fully spiking
networks with multi compartment multi
compartment neurons I should say this
really it really ought to be said
especially on after the last stuff that
I talked about getting the stuff to work
in spiky networks is still hard it still
it doesn't perform as well as we will
if we did it in non spiking networks so
there's a whole variety of issues I
think to sort out there yep so here's
here's my here's my I think my honest
sort of take on this is that what we
didn't really do much of in this paper
and I think what we would have to head
is really that question the question
that I or the the idea that I mentioned
a bit earlier that you really want
forward and backward passes to be going
on roughly simultaneously and that in
order to do that dendrites might be a
real help because of like if you have a
single compartment into which everything
arrives simultaneously how can you help
but basically you know have to separate
your forward and backward passes so yeah
there's there's a conversation to have
here maybe we can take yeah I think I'm
running up on time but who it was worth
asking
so I'll just I I think that was I mean I
think there really is a bit of a
positive side of the story here which is
that neuroscience is telling us all
sorts of things complexify what cortex
looks like what the cells look like what
the circuits look like and so I think
there's two real interesting directions
to my mind one is one is on the nurse
the sort of machine learning front which
is look if we write down a couple more
constraints like weight tying and a few
of these I think like low bits in terms
of the backward pass weights I think
it's a real is a real one as well
do we have can we find any algorithms
that will learn to do really hard
problems right like like imagenet and I
think that there's still work to do
there I mean as far as I know we just
don't have those algorithms and on the
neuroscience front we I think we should
step up and start explicitly looking to
identify the role of feedback in weight
updates so I think something even the
some of the simplest experiments you
could dream up where you would say
establish a plasticity protocol in sort
of forward weights and then
mess around with the feedback coming
into neurons and and look at how that
changes the plasticity protocol in those
forward going weights those experiments
I think in the past had probably not
been easy to do but we have the tools to
do it now and we probably should look
into those kinds of things directly and
explicitly and I think I'll probably
kind of wrap up there and take questions
and see how things go that was the first
one sorry there's a scale of spatial
skill in which it's very important for
us synaptic plasticity which is very sub
neuron and sort of dendrite level and
even ten microns within within a
dendrite where it's enough to cluster
where synapses influence each other in
terms of potentiation and so on but
certainly dendrite level because there
are proteins which go up you know with
dendrite that's true then you need seems
like the feedback can't just be cell
wide as you're depicting here you would
need to instruct synapses on a much
finer spatial scale you might we you
might need to I mean I think as far as
I'm concerned there's just you might
need to and I would certainly wouldn't
say no I think there's just a lot of
open questions here I mean maybe you
don't to get decent enough learning I
think I think that's where the sort of
the question falls down is maybe maybe
those feedback and signals can be
roughly cells like cell specific and
that's enough I mean at the moment even
convincing people that they should
really be cell specific and that that
that cells specific feedback would carry
information about the downstream
structure of the brain and that that
would be I would be happy if people were
on board with that I think you're
talking about like even another level
which would be great but yeah
are all in that some static tasks yeah
absolutely
let me hopefully I can preempt this the
only reason I mean I'd like of course we
should do things like the things that
were talked about yesterday like these
pred nets and so on of course the brain
is is really I think built around doing
temporal things I I think that and of
course we should like look at these
things in temporal tasks I have looked
at and thought about this stuff a lot in
the a temporal case basically for ease I
think that it's not like things get much
easier when you go to temporal now some
of the ideas about how you construct the
algorithms might get easier for example
I mean if you have if you if you took an
algorithm like this like different
Stargate prop and and you thought about
you know if you thought about what's
needed here in the a temporal case you
need to still kind of do a forward pass
and a backward pass rightful ones in
order to work on that specific template
like that specific static image if
you're doing this in time right then
maybe it's suffice is to kind of do
these relatively local loops and you're
doing this sort of temporally and making
predictions about the lower layer the
lower layer kind of at a you know in a
temporal in a temporal fashion which
doesn't require full backward and
forward and backward passes okay so I
absolutely so there's another there's a
whole other kettle of fish around like
temporal credit assignment and I
absolutely wouldn't deny that I guess
I'm saying that you this is kind of if
you like an easy benchmark and we're not
even hitting that so you're saying like
look you have a problem like this but we
also on top of that have these temporal
credit assignment issues and I
completely agree and I'm saying we can't
even solve the static ones and we're not
even I think we're not even a place
where we have sort of sufficiently been
able to address how you would do this in
the static case
thank you very much for very talk right
but I'm trying to understand it but my
mind around this you start with the
statements that that the just a single
backwards single single single feedback
signal is not good enough right and so
on the other hand there is back
propagation where you get a single pair
in your own practice pitabread
yes to getting a signal per neuron it's
just that the signal is not exactly the
backdrop it's correlated to back from
someone out right and so maybe then this
is I mean if I were to have to put a
skeptic hat on right this is not
surprising that if you have the same
number of feedback signals as in back
home and they are correlated with it
then you would be able to do something
good right yeah can we come and take
this argument sensor put some closer to
z2 to the left side where the the number
of feedback signals is much smaller than
the number of neurons that you're trying
to sure it might be I mean it might be
and I think there's like I said that
spectrum is relatively under explored
and it'll be great to see more there I
mean to me when I look at the when I
look at cortex
I do see a whole bunch of single neurons
specific feedback from later areas say
from v1 like from v2 back to v1 so to me
it kind of looks like the machinery
exists there to do relatively targeted
even single neuron feedback but it's
absolutely possible like look those
things are as I said almost certainly
approximations of knowing about your
downstream structure and as you say
there might be sort of things closer to
the left-hand side of that spectrum that
work really well and I think we don't
know yes okay
this is from cotton Ramachandra and he
asks which is biologically plausible the
reinforcement learning or the use of
spiking neural networks approach for the
computational modeling of the brain
which can I say both
I mean wait yeah i yeah i'm happy to say
both there may be he's out here then
they'll have to we'll have to live with
that yeah thought about the one I think
fundamental question in the way how
brains apparently learn for example the
task of imagenet not like really
classifying visual objects hey there
seems to be really no genetically
encoded no you have face areas or so and
brains in particular no kind of parts of
the tissue and you also you have a
learning schedule right that you first
learn simple tasks and then you build on
this no ramifications so this suggests
that possibly it's unnecessary
or maybe this only arises because you
want to learn everything at once in the
network yeah I think I think this is a
great that's right I think this is a
great worry
here's my my rough thinking about it and
I think it's one of these things where
the questions are genuinely empirical
and we need to just do work and and dig
into these things to me it's true that
yes we have some Gabor like things that
look pretty evident in v1 pretty early
on and then we have things like face
areas which seem to have biases towards
maybe face like things but especially
once you move actually quite quickly
when you move there's the structure the
number of bits dictating which neuron
ought to do which and how it's sort of
wired up and so on there are there are
there are just huge numbers of bits in
those networks which I think are not
there from genetics just because there
aren't that many bits
I think conveyed by the genes in terms
of how you should wire this neuron very
explicitly to this neuron and so to my
mind that there's so many of those bits
that even when you talk about okay
there's a bit of a bias to having a face
area and so on you really I think are
gonna have to confront the sort of
general deep learning question and
another sign of that I would say is that
even though we can complain to
the border like patches and face areas
and so on the fact remains that a human
can reach incredible incredible skills
it's something like go which I think had
you know which really requires big deep
networks to compute value functions and
policy functions I think and and for
which you know evolution had nothing to
say about that and and I think that the
the sort of the synaptic weights you
know priors over the synaptic weights
really weren't helping you build that
network so that would kind of be my
rough answer but I see what you mean
what you what you mean I think was this
yeah sorry okay I think I mean basically
I think you could imagine taking
something very much like target prop
like ideas which basically are trained
with with Auto encoding losses here and
you could imagine doing this kind of
unrolled in time and I think the kinds
of algorithms you'd write down starting
from that point and thinking about
predictive coding or sorry if you
extended this in time the sort of
algorithms you'd write down and play
around with would look very much like
the sort of predictive coding ballpark
basically
or do you think there's sort of
representation I see okay right and so
that that's yeah maybe back to that
slide where I said like people have
looked and they see sort of things that
look vaguely like the networks that were
trained by back prop that is a good
question and I think again it's just one
of these things that we don't know
enough about there's some evidence that
the the there is some evidence I would
say now especially in deep networks
where maybe deep networks with multiple
components to them and things like this
that the optimizer does matter in terms
of the representations you end up with
so there's some evidence for that I
think you basically I think that's what
you're talking about right and and so
you could even see roughly the same
error and then the the actual the result
the actual internal results you see look
quite different I mean actually there's
a really good I don't know if it's been
published yet but I think they've spoken
it about it at a couple conferences I
think maybe both from the DeCarlo lab
and from previous court lab where if you
take big rez nets instead of things that
look more like Alex net and vgg if you
take big rez nets and you train those on
image net and then you do this post hoc
analysis where you compare them to the
brain those residents do actually a fair
bit better on image net but the actual
representations look a lot less like
what you see in monkey I T and v4 so so
I think they're the architect at least
the architecture there has pulled has
pulled the representations away from
being similar yep
Ransome usually sure there absolutely is
I mean I think I mean we can talk about
ideas like maybe you know people are
using hippocampus to store stuff and do
more iid like sampling as you do with
replay buffers and so on but in general
sure I would say though that that kind
of only makes all these problems harder
and maybe that's a general comment right
I think that like time has come up
several times like this kind of thing
the the I think by I think I'm not
saying absolutely that looking at the
supervise case is like the thing to do
obviously there's all these other
complexities I guess I'm saying that you
know it's good to start simple if and
when you can and maybe that'll just be I
mean it will be insufficient at some
point but I think having answers even in
that simple case would be a handle on
things in that simple case is good so I
totally agree but
good question
I mean I think specifically we were
interested in the idea although we're
not there yet as Peter very keenly
pointed out we were specifically
interested in this idea of of imagining
being able to have sort of feedback
activity being integrated separately
from your feed-forward activity and that
those things could live together at the
same time but sure no reason not to look
at those but that was kind of the reason
specifically to look at Margit multi
compartment scenarios yeah
[Applause]